- No question.
The quickest way to happiness
is accountability.
When people start looking
for somebody else to be at fault,
whether it's the
government, or their aunt,
or some, or their fucking boss,
they always lose.
(men yelling)
You've got your perspective.
(dramatic music)
(crowd cheering)
I just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
(people chattering)
(luggage rolling on metal)
- [Andy] This will be a
great podcast to be honest.
- [Man On Phone] I think
it's going to be Amazon
- What the fuck?
- [Man On Phone] Yeah, it's
the most underrated company
on the internet today.
- Let's fucking go.
I want you to get what
Amazon's stock price was
on April 6, 2011.
- [Man On Phone] So everybody is trying
to figure out which companies
could win this spectacular--
- You can start it with like,
"Hey, you were listening to Gary
"and bought a thousand shares on Amazon
"on this day for this price
"if you work this much now,
"that'd be an amazing video."
Two companies really stick in my craw.
Amazon and Netflix.
They were just good entrepreneurs.
Everybody's trying to figure out
which company is gonna
win this big tech battle.
I've been thinking it's gonna be Amazon.
I actually think Amazon,
yeah, is the most underrated
company on the internet today.
This company is always showing
the ability to innovate,
they understood commerce,
they went out and bought
Zappos for culture.
You know I like that 'cause
that's thank you economy.
Every day that goes by, I'm
continued to be impressed
by how Amazon executes,
delivers and creates innovation
that is bringing money to its bottom line,
and so for you sitting now watching,
I gotta be honest,
you know, I'm no Jim Cramer,
though a lot of people think I get crazy.
I think Amazon may win this whole thing.
(upbeat music)
That's fucking amazing!
(hip hop music)
- Fireside chat with Jessica Alba.
This is just a podcast we're doing.
- What up, podcast?
This was a talk I did
about 18 months ago with Jessica Alba.
It was really great for the whole company,
and just a lot of insights
that I think are timeless,
which is why I wanted
everybody to read it,
or read it? (laughs)
Listen to it.
I hope you enjoy it.
Thank you so much for watching.
Jesus Christ!
Listening to the podcast.
I don't know why I want you guys to read
and watch my podcast.
I'm very passionate that audio
and listening is the future.
I'm actually recording this
while I'm about to give this talk in DC.
And I've been on vacation
for about a week,
and literally, I just could
see the rust coming out
in this little pre-read.
So, anyway hit me up on Twitter and say,
"Hey, Rusty Vee!" (laughs)
And, enjoy this podcast!
- That's what is bold--
- What I just did is
what nobody ever does.
- I know.
- And it's so human.
- Right.
- And it's so much what?
- Yeah, it's 100%.
That's exactly right.
(laughs)
You know how I also feel about steroids?
I think people should do steroids.
(Gary laughs)
Like I actually, like kinda, logically,
now let me preface this
since this is all on record.
I'm not educated at all.
But there's something
that feels intuitively...
(men laughing)
for an average male may
just wanna take steroid.
I think it's a good idea.
Is this for the podcast?
- [Andy] I believe it's a microclip.
- Yeah, doesn't matter either way.
Hey guys, we're about the
watch and/or listen to,
depending on how you roll,
is a two minutes and change on my thoughts
about a lot of my
friends and acquaintances
in the business world talking
about, you know, different drugs,
different, you know, aspects of the mind,
and it was just a fun little clip.
(solemn music)
Forget about politics,
I just don't wanna talk about it,
but I wanna talk about one thing
that I just want everybody
know about America.
If you're willing to try to
cross the border illegally
into our country,
knowing that you are gonna be potentially,
and now highly likely, separated
from your four to eight-year-old
for six months potentially,
imagine what the fuck you're running from.
We're just so lucky.
And we're sick.
First of all, we're just like,
I couldn't imagine if the
first 25 years of my life
were spent in Soviet Russia.
My grandfathers both went
to jail for being like me.
I get to be put on a pedestal.
Look at me.
Look at me in my class photo.
It's like knife, cheese and...
Oh did Winestock?
Jason Cast and Michael Wong.
Wakil Shaw,
fuck, I remember a lot of.
Michael Sosha.
I'm fucking killin' it!
- [Andy] Wait, this is all off of memory?
- Oh yeah, I just did that off memory!
And I moved in seventh grade
so I haven't seen these
people since '87 or something!
When did they officially acknowledge
that there was a poop emoji?
'Cause wasn't there like an
ice cream cone for a while?
Like weren't they trying to say that?
Or what that just hearsay?
- I don't know.
- I don't know, yeah.
What made you think of that?
- I spelled poop, and it shows it.
I do my emojis now by spelling them out.
- Me, too.
- Interesting really.
- It's faster.
- It's way faster than
fucking trying to find it.
- When I type on Instagram,
I type the name--
- Of the emoji--
- And then I pick the,
the emoji shows up in the bottom there.
- I'm pissed when I type it in
and it's not coming up, the emoji.
- Yeah.
- What the hell is that?
- Mm-hmm.
- Interesting.
- There's Zach.
- [Gary Playing On Phone] And
coming up on six hours sleep,
so you have 18 hours, you
have 18 goddamn hours!
(laughs)
- [Gary Playing On Phone] I
wanna know what you're doing
with your 18 hours.
(rock n' roll music)
First in Line, what's up?
I'm trying to get some light here.
First in Line, I'm going
on stage in DC right now.
teamgaryvee is streaming it live.
Click there.
Make sure you follow the
teamgaryvee Instagram account.
Tons of awesome shit there.
Hope you enjoy this keynote.
Done.
- When am I on?
- Now.
- Alright, Andy, go get a good spot.
- [Announcer] Ladies and
gentleman, Gary Vaynerchuk!
(groovy music)
(crowd cheers)
- What up?
What up?
One thing I'm positive about is how
ROI negative complaining is
and how much I'm trying to
suffocate the practice of it.
It has been remarkably
important to me in understanding
that everything that
I'm not happy about has,
is on me.
It's a remarkably interesting brain twist.
The amount of energy spent on things
that you can't control
versus being accountable
to what you can control
has been a huge separator for me
in the last four, five
years as I dug deep.
And so, if I was able to have
a couple of things happen
out of this talk this morning,
one is just self-awareness.
Just like do you actually
know who you are?
So many people wishing they're something
instead of understanding what they are.
Number two is accountability.
No question,
the quickest way to
happiness is accountability.
When people start looking
for somebody else to be at fault,
whether it's the
government, or their aunt,
or their fucking boss, they always lose.
I really wanna make sure
that people leave here
knowing who they are.
Do you understand yourself?
Do you actually have a situation
where you judge yourself within yourself?
Or do you allow other people's opinions
to dictate your life?
There is nothing,
nothing more difficult
than navigating your life
based on somebody else's opinion.
(crowd cheers)
- Have you learned something from Gary?
- Can you hold this for a second?
You got a pen?
- It's in the shoe.
- [Woman] Gary!
- [Man] Gary!
(crowd shouting)
- Whose?
Yours?
- I'll take it.
(laughing)
- Welcome to the neighborhood!
- I appreciate that!
- You did a great job.
- Thank you, man!
- Thank you for this!
- Yeah, it's really
nice to spend some time.
I've always felt comfortable with it.
When I started vlogging
and had Drock film me,
there was already vlogging,
but like casing others,
they were doing it themselves.
So me having a different
human doing it was
three years ago was a little intense.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome, you're welcome.
- [Woman] Will you read it for them?
- You got it.
One life.
Do something.
I think people take things for granted.
Do you know you're more
likely to win the lottery
10 times than be alive?
I love that shit!
400 trillion to one according
to current scientists.
400 trillion to one!
Everybody in this room
is likely to get hit
by lightening seven times
more likely than being alive.
That's crazy!
Steve, that's crazy.
(woman laughing)
All right, let's do this photo.
- [Woman] Cool.
- Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
(laughing)
Thank you, guys.
("Matador" by Nate Rose)
♪ You're better out
running with the bulls ♪
♪ Than running with that bullshit, yeah ♪
♪ You're better out
running with the bulls ♪
♪ Than running with that bullshit, yeah ♪
♪ You're better out
running with the bulls ♪
♪ Than running with that bullshit, yeah ♪
♪ You're better out
running with the bulls ♪
♪ Than running with that bullshit, yeah ♪
♪ You're better out
running with the bulls ♪
♪ Than running with that bullshit ♪
♪ Knock it out the park while
I'm sitting in the bull pit ♪
♪ I'm too ahead of my time ♪
♪ You could have been on my luck ♪
♪ You're doing better than mine ♪
♪ I'm in the rhythm and daft ♪
♪ For every nickel and dime ♪
♪ Think that I'm sick of mine ♪
♪ Sick of when there is
someone who can rhyme ♪
♪ They wanna pick and then try to ♪
- And it's definitely way
fucking more competitive
now than it was--
- 18 months ago.
- It may be even like six months ago.
- Yeah, makes sense.
- So I mean, aside from like the masses
that you were talking to today,
what's the next shit beyond Facebook ads?
- No, it's that.
It's contextual creative though.
I think we're getting better is like
I'll like
I told them and it like really
clicked recently for us.
Because I've been on it,
but we haven't been executing on it.
I was like, "If we're gonna make content,"
like literally in this greenroom
an hour ago, two hours ago.
I said to them no, let me just make an ad,
and be like hey, USC grads, like da-da-da,
and then you run it against USC grads.
- Yeah.
- Like it's just contextual.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's less, you know like,
Facebook and Instagram
are content platforms,
not advertising platforms.
When you want ads what you
realize is that you're at the,
no matter how top nerd you are,
you're at the mercy of the creative.
- Yeah yeah, yeah.
And when the creative
kills, the cause drops.
- The end.
- The engagement goes, yeah.
- The engagement goes through the roof.
You know, your earned
CPMs go through the roof,
which drops down your actual cost.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And so like--
- Your relevance score, all that stuff-
- Just the costs because
if you're getting shares
and word of mouth
and you're getting an
extra million impressions
that you didn't pay for
because of actual social media.
People forgot about that part.
Well then, the creative is the answer.
- Yeah.
- It's a really good song to So Up.
("So Up" by Euro Gotit)
- What time's our flight?
- 10.
- So I wanna leave at 8:40.
Like 8:50 at the latest.
Or just Swae Lee.
- [Swae Lee] Gary, the
way you've talking, man,
cash, money shit, bro,
you've open up a lot of eyes
with what you're doing, bro.
Start Jimmy, bro.
- [Jimmy] I don't got it.
Hey, Gary, we got to link up.
Talk some cash, shit on these folks, man.
Let them know who their originators is
in this motherfuckin'.
'Cause I got a lot of
kids, too in the rap game.
Matter of fact, I don't claim 'em.
Take this on.
But I got a lot of kids in the rap game.
I gotta keep switching up my swagger.
(background noise drowns out other sounds)
- Got you, G.
♪ When you told me that I was next ♪
♪ As you're talking biggie
or punch on to cash me ♪
♪ And my new drug, JFK with some shaz ♪
♪ I know that ain't how you run ♪
♪ I'm so up right now ♪
♪ I'm so up ♪
♪ I'm so up right now, y'all ♪
♪ I've been down so long ♪
♪ That it feels so good just
to say I'm up right now ♪
- Free is best when you can do your thing.
I couldn't be more passionate
about you going to downtown whatever
,wherever the fuck you are now,
and like doing it for somebody,
like literally like hey, pizza Joe,
are you redoing your front of your store?
Just get it on ink.
The biggest issue for kids a lot of time
is proof of concept.
- Right.
- Free is an awfully
tough thing to pass on.
One thing with free.
Do something for free,
then lets you do what
the fuck you wanna do.
Free for the sake of free,
but the owner of the fucking
store doesn't let you do shit,
isn't good for you.
- Right.
- You need a
you need like Louis Vuitton.
You need like Virgil to be like
that's the freshest shit I've
ever seen on social media.
Who did that?
You see where I'm going?
We just did something free
for that's gonna change our company.
Now!
Vayner.
150 fuckin' million revenue.
- You're kidding?
- Free!
Changed my business.
♪ I'm so up right now ♪
♪ I'm so up ♪
♪ I'm so up right now, y'all ♪
♪ I've been down so long ♪
♪ And it feels to good just to say ♪
♪ I'm up right now ♪